With The Mandalorian's second chapter, we
dive a little deeper than ever before into
the state of galaxy immediately following
the fall of the Empire.
While a lot has changed, some things stay
the same.
Here are a few of the best callbacks.
By the beginning of Chapter Two, The Mandalorian
is trying to get "the asset" a creature that
appears to be some kind of adorable baby Yoda
back to his mysterious client, a remnant of
the crumbling Empire, but it's a treacherous
and violent journey.
This trip includes a run-in with Jawas, a
race of creature very recognizable to Star
Wars fans, visually distinct because of their
hooded cloaks, short stature, and glowing
eyes.
And also their tendency to steal anything
that isn't nailed down.
After they strip down his ship, the Razor
Crest, the Mandalorian blasts any Jawas that
get in his path on a violent mission to get
his stuff back, turning them into dust as
they poof away without a trace.
Later on, Kuiil remarks to the Mandalorian
that the creatures "really don't like him
for some reason."
The Mandalorian replies, "Well, I did disintegrate
a few of them."
This subtly calls back to a brief exchange
in The Empire Strikes Back between Darth Vader
and a collection of dicey-looking bounty hunters,
in which the Sith lord tells them that he
wants the crew of the Millennium Falcon brought
to him alive, by any means necessary.
And addressing Boba Fett, Vader makes a point
of specifying "No disintegrations."
In other words, these Mandalorian bounty hunters
just love blasting their enemies into paste
and are probably known to do so when given
the chance.
And while we're talking about fancy Mandalorian
weapons, it's pretty nice to see that wrist-mounted
flamethrower make an appearance.
Can jetpacks be too far behind?
While the full identity of "the asset" is
not yet clear by the end of the second chapter
of The Mandalorian, it's obvious to anyone
with even a passing familiarity of Star Wars
that the little guy is a very young version
of a Yoda-type alien.
probably designed to be a best-selling toy
this Christmas.
While this creature-with-no-name is reportedly
50 years old, he's still baby-like in many
ways... but at the same time, very wise and
Yoda-like in others.
Specifically, he can definitely use the Force,
even without apparently going through years
of fancy Jedi training.
He lifts a gigantic Mud Horn off the ground
with a bit of effort, not unlike that time
when Yoda thought real hard and lifted Luke's
X-wing right out of the swamps of Dagobah.
The Force takes many forms, including healing
abilities, and this tiny Yoda successor may
also have that power, as seen when he attempts
to heal The Mandalorian's wound.
The great Obi-Wan Kenobi may have used this
ability to help Luke recover from the Tusken
Raider attack in A New Hope, but the ability
to heal with the Force has been a bit iffy
and weirdly defined in Star Wars canon…
until now.
And it also begs the question are Yoda's people
just naturally super-strong with the Force?
It's hard to tell under all of the special
effects that make him look like an Ugnaught,
but Kuiil the Mandalorian's ally, friend,
and lifesaver is portrayed by three-time Oscar-nominated
actor Nick Nolte, who brings his specific
world-weary style of acting to the loner alien.
But really, Kuiil doesn't have to work alone
if he doesn't want to.
After they've escaped a whole lot of trouble
in Chapter Two of the series, The Mandalorian
suggests making their relationship a bit more
permanent.
He offers Kuiil a well-paid spot on his crew,
but Kuiil respectfully rejects it.
"I am honored, but I have worked a lifetime
to finally be free of servitude."
That's a weighty statement, but his reasoning
can be traced back to The Empire Strikes Back
and a visit to Cloud City.
Ugnaughts were briefly depicted as the industrious
backbone of that society, hired because of
their work ethic and given a home after their
own planet was decimated by slavery, according
to official Star Wars lore.
As a man who was once without a home in the
galaxy, leaving behind his hard-earned patch
of land just doesn't seem like the better
option.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Mandalorian
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.